cómo avanzan las manifestaciones que
nivel de participación podés observar
Hola Santiago Buenas noches casi aquí en
la capital francesa Pues estamos a
varios centros de metros cientos de
metros yo diría eh 150 metros quizás de
la Plaza de la bastilla lugar histórico
donde va a finalizar la protesta de hoy
según estimaciones de la confederación
general del trabajo uno de los ocho
sindicatos que han convocado a esta
protesta en las calles de París se
manifestaron cerca de 400.000 personas
es una cifra similar a la de la primera
manifestación contra esta polémica y e
impopular reforma de pensiones y un poco
menor inferior a la registrada el día 31
de enero sin embargo no deja de ser
impresionante todavía hay personas
caminando desde las dos de la tarde es
decir han pasado casi seis horas desde
el inicio de esta manifestación sin
embargo ha sucedido todo en la calma son
manifestaciones pacíficas hasta el
momento hemos visto personas incluso
cantando tocando tambores y sobre todo
muy ingeniosos con alguno con unas
especies de remix muy populares a las
que han de las cuales han sustituido su
letra original para incluirle cantos
contra el presidente Emmanuel macron Eso
sí hay diputados opositores que alertan
que mientras el gobierno continúe
haciendo caso omiso a estas
manifestaciones pues pueda que en algún
momento de generen y se vuelvan más
violentas Luis Miguel Bueno corriéndonos
un poco de lo que ocurre en las calles
No estas huelgas y protestas se dan
luego de que ayer precisamente la
legislación de esta reforma pensional
comenzará a ser debatida en la asamblea
nacional francesa qué podemos esperar
que ocurra allí teniendo en cuenta el
equilibrio de fuerzas y que escenarios
se abrirían entonces
Pues mira Precisamente lo que sucede en
la asamblea nacional es uno de los
aspectos que más atizan la ira aquí en
las calles de París porque en este
momento se está debatiendo ese proyecto
de ley dentro de la cámara baja
precisamente del parlamento qué ha
sucedido que la primera ministra
Elizabeth ha decidido de alguna forma
ofrecer una especie de concesión algunos
partidos políticos en especial al de
Centro derecha los republicanos a
digamos implementado una medida ofrecido
implementar una medida una
transformación a esta ley para que las
personas que trabajan entre venta y 21
años los que comienzan a trabajar a esa
edad puedan jubilarse un año antes
completamente insuficientes ridículos
para algunos parlamentarios y esto ha
sido otra muestra de que el gobierno no
escucha lo que sucede aquí en las calles
sino que se concentra en el juego
político dentro de la asamblea nacional
ha sido jornadas muy tensas la de hoy lo
ha sido también hay diputados de
reagrupación nacional el partido de
ultraderecha y también de la propia
mayoría presidencial han recibido
mensajes amenazantes para que abandonen
el hemiciclo y esto nos da una medida de
cuán tenso es el debate dentro de la
asamblea nacional otro asunto importante
Sí parece que las huelgas van a
continuar celebrándose o desarrollándose
mientras el gobierno
continúe en su posición firme y como lo
ha hecho hasta el